the rallies across russia have been
banned but that didn't stop people and
kaburovsk from coming out
to make their voices heard the eastern
city has seen months of protests against
the kremlin
but this rally was specifically in
support of president vladimir putin's
fiercest critic alexei navalny
there were soon scuffles with police
authorities have gone to great lengths
to prevent
such acts of defiance including
arresting several of navalny's top aides
in the lead-up to saturday's protests
the kremlins described the rallies as
unlawful and warned of tough
consequences
calls for participation in illegal mass
actions constitute an administrative
violation
and can lead to punishment including
arrest
it's alexi navalny's arrest last week
that's behind the protests
he was taken into custody soon after he
touched down in moscow
on a flight from germany where he'd
received months of treatment for a
poisoning which nearly killed him
he's accused president putin of ordering
his murder
authorities say navalny violated the
terms of a 2014 conviction for financial
misdeeds
and jailed him for 30 days in a video
posted soon after his arrest he said
don't be silent resist take to the
streets no one will protect us
except ourselves his supporters have
answered his calls
dozens of videos on tech talk have gone
viral showing students taking down
pictures of putin in their classrooms
or covering his photo with navalny's
image instead
the kremlins warned online platforms
they could face
fines of up to fifty thousand dollars
for allowing content that
encourages protests russia's largest
social media network v
contact has blocked all pages linked to
the rallies
the russian investigative committee has
initiated a criminal case on enticement
of minors into illegal activities
that pose a danger to their lives
carried out via internet and social
media
mass protests have led to navalny's
release from custody before
but some analysts believe the tactic
won't work this time
because he's become too much of a threat
to president putin's grip
on power alex o'brien al jazeera